now on good day hurricane and Recovery
efforts continue the death toll is
climbing we have an update from the Gulf
Coast while the search for survivors
continues
plus what if stress and sleep have in
common Well turns out a lot how your
everyday worries may be interrupting all
your snooze time and it's Donny Osmond
week here on good day we're sitting down
with the actor singer former Teen Idol
talking about his past present and
future Good Day Las Vegas starts right
now
now this is good day Las Vegas live
local now waking up here on a Monday
morning with beautiful weather outside
at least right now it's time to open up
those windows good morning I'm Heather
Mills John has the week off so you'll be
starting your mornings off with us stay
tuned for the Donny stuff we've got
plenty more of that but first Sherry we
got to talk about these temperatures I
know not everybody loves it but I could
still go in the swimming pool I know and
a lot of people I'm sure are still
jumping in the pool for sure a beautiful
clear skies on this Monday morning it
was a warm weekend we were in the mid to
low 90s from Friday through yesterday
the mornings are cooling down a little
bit but we're actually just right about
where we were yesterday at this hour
right now 74 degrees but the humidity is
up a little 35 percent the dew points in
the 40s again so we had dried out
towards the end of last week and then a
little more humidity again over the
weekend I think you can feel it out
there and that could be very significant
for the afternoon sunrise at 6 37 sunset
at 6 21. so we'll get through the
morning with plenty of sunshine we'll be
warming to the low 80's mid-morning mid
80's by noon start to see maybe some
clouds around as that moisture gets
cooked up a little bit and we've got
very slight chances for thunderstorms in
the afternoon and evening hours
yesterday we saw thunderstorms out
around Boulder City today that it could
include the Las Vegas Valley so we can't
rule it out we'll talk about where this
moisture is coming from and how long
it's going to last in your most accurate
weather now forecast right now we've got
to get to the roads and the drive if
you're headed out this morning Nate
Tannenbaum is here with a look at the
traffic thank you Sherry good morning
and the freeway that is the trouble spot
is the 15. there's one crash on the
freeway one crash nearby and it is
getting heavy with more and more cars on
the road so the southbound Drive is okay
out of the spaghetti Bowl you're just
tapping the brakes with a lot of company
the first crash I'm going to tell you
about is eastbound on Flamingo just
right at the I-15 so you're coming from
Decatur or Valley View looking to get
onto the freeway well here's what you
got to do you got to get out of the left
lane so the Rio Hotel will be over here
on your right just off the screen these
tail lights are the westbounders coming
from the freeway headed towards the Rio
and the Gold Coast or whatever so folks
are still able to get onto the 15 but if
you're looking to get over to the strip
get out of the left lane there meantime
on the south end so down around Southern
Highlands this one is a troublemaker
Northbound on the five on the 15 it is
for sure backing up a live picture is
showing you they're taking up the right
lane I believe the exit to Star Avenue
may be blocked through traffic is
getting through but move over to the
left Heather take your time out there
Nate thank you up following some
breaking news this morning here we have
reports now Metro investigating two
unrelated homicides both happen
overnight the first near Tropicana and
Nellis very few details here at this
early hour we're working together some
more information for you the second
happened near Eastern and Fremont again
not much known about what exactly
happened but we will keep you up to date
on eightnewsnow.com and inside the 8
News Now app as soon as we have some new
information now although homicides may
be down across the valley through the
first half of the Year concerns about
violent crime are still up law
enforcement agencies working very hard
to crack down so it's more important
than ever to have eyes and ears in the
community they develop those
relationships through events like
National Night Out our Candace Charles
joining us live now to talk about that
big event Candace good morning to you
good morning Heather good morning folks
yes this is one of the many things you
can check out tomorrow at National Night
Out but as Heather explained it's also
just a chance for you guys to come out
and hang out with some of these metro
police officers and I'm joined by one of
them one of the finest Jeremy Robinson
thank you so much officer Robertson for
hanging out with us this morning now you
are kind of the go-to guy on this new
UTV that you guys got from Howard Hughes
Corp right so tell me a little bit about
how this works for you guys and how's
this going to help you guys out well
this is a great uh new tool that we can
use we can get in the desert areas
because we are surrounded uh to the west
side with a lot of desert areas a lot of
trails so we're able to get in we can
help people out we can go look for
things whenever there's an issue or if
someone gets stuck we can get out to
those areas
pretty fancy one I gotta say we are very
blessed to have this uh Decked Out
machine we have air conditioning so come
summertime it's going to be comfortable
for our officers we also have heat so as
winter is coming up we'll be able to
stay warm we were able to get the GPS
package on this so if we are out in the
trails we're able to see what trails
we're on and Mark different locations
with the GPS
this UTV holds six people has six seat
belts so we could put six people in this
if we had to get someone out of a desert
area we were able to do that and it's on
the front of the UTV we have the bright
LEDs so if we do have to have this out
at night we will be able to use it on
the trails and be able to see where
we're going now I know you guys have the
canines out here tomorrow someone Sam
but for things like this how exciting is
it for the community I think it's very
exciting you know we have a great night
to where you can come out meet your
local officers get to talk to them ask
questions uh we're excited to to mingle
with the crowd see the little kids so
please bring out your families bring out
yourself have a nice night out the
weather's perfect for this awesome thank
you so much officer Robertson we
appreciate you of course you can check
this all out tomorrow at National Night
Out Tuesday October 4th from 5 to 7 and
they'll be right here in downtown
Summerlin you know I got you covered
with all the details to go
daynewsnow.com to check that out for now
live from downtown Summerlin I'm Candace
Charles 8 news now hi Candace that's
great great to see inside of it it's
going to be super helpful for them
happening now and then today President
Biden expected in Puerto Rico to tour
damage Left Behind from Hurricane Fiona
but all eyes are still on Florida this
morning where crews are searching for
survivors and finding more bodies after
Hurricane Ian laid waste to the state's
western coast right now the death toll
stands at 82 in Florida another four in
North Carolina Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis says that Ann brought in so
much water he's calling it a 500 year
flood event and for many the damage
isn't done yet in some parts of Florida
flooding is getting worse the St John's
river in Seminole County keeps Rising
those nearby actually need boats just to
get to their homes
we're at the deep end so I think these
first three houses or four houses are
all flooded and the rest are just
getting flooded in the Fort Myers area
officials say the damage Left Behind is
life-changing and catastrophic
as a new week begins more than half a
million Floridians remain without power
and now Category 2 hurricane or lean
preparing to strike Mexico today
bringing Heavy Rain potential for severe
flooding it's to the western coast of
the country near Mazatlan the National
Hurricane Center is also warning about
flash flooding and possible landslides
in Southwest Mexico through Tuesday
[Music]
this morning many visitors to our city
will be headed home after a very
emotional weekend across our Valley as
they came together with locals to honor
five years since one October tributes
began early Saturday morning with a
sunrise ceremony at the Clark County
Amphitheater there speakers remembered
the victims with 58 seconds of Silence
one for every person killed that night
Quentin Robbins 20 from Henderson Nevada
[Music]
it was just a portion of Saturday
night's annual reading of the names
where survivors as well as victims
families gathered together to remember
and continue to mourn we spoke with
Survivor Pat Dalton Saturday evening
just before the ceremony he's a Las
Vegas local and he recalled memories of
the days immediately following one
October and he says even five years
later those memories stand out very
clearly in his mind
from The Darkest Day this community has
ever faced on October 2nd was the most
beautiful coming together of a community
I've ever seen
we were all one there was no division
Dalton says for him and dozens of other
survivors the memories of that night
really bound them together in what they
call a forever family Sherry well many
of those families and hundreds of others
also came out Sunday morning for the
Vegas strong 5K Runners and Walkers
choosing to participate to honor those
lost five years ago and be on the road
to Healing it was a morning of Hope and
I was honored to emcee the event ahead
of the big started along with Nate
Heather and JC Fernandez we broadcast
much of the race live that more
yesterday morning downtown Las Vegas
more than 2 000 people registered for
the race it was a wonderful morning and
a big congratulations to the overall
mail winner gamini Suga fidasa for
finishing first overall and just so you
know 100 percent of the race proceeds
benefit victims funds needs in our
community as well as raise money for
college scholarships and it's a
wonderful wonderful event it's been
going five years strong Heather a great
event it was great to see everybody out
there
something else kind of exciting for
silver and black you're waking up this
morning with a win the Raiders clinching
their first victory of the Season facing
off against the Denver Broncos yesterday
afternoon here at home that's after of
course they had three losses in a row so
the final score yesterday
32-23 the Raiders play again a week from
today against the Kansas City Chiefs in
Kansas City
still have here on good day we're
thrilled of course that you're waking up
with us this morning but the question is
how'd you sleep last night well if the
answer is not so good
scientists may have an answer for you
that's coming up plus a young star
turned Teen Idol turned showman
Superstar Donny Osmond sits down with me
for a one-on-one what he says about his
current show what you can expect and
well Sherry what you might not expect
wow still after all these years some
unexpected from from Dottie hey we may
have some thunderstorms this afternoon
that may throw you a curveball clear
skies through the morning hours 80s by
noon low 90's again staying extra warm
but yes slight chances of thunderstorms
this afternoon and evening so be
prepared for that what's the rest rest
of the week hold it's in your most
accurate weather now forecast right
after the break six to eleven we'll be
right back
sponsored by Dollar Loan Center Live
this is good day Las Vegas
now he's a singer actor host dancer part
of our City's past and present Donny
Osmond a legend in Show Business he just
announced his extended residency at
Harrah's and I had a chance to sit down
with him and kind of pull back the
curtain a little bit as kicks off our
Donny Osmond week and here's what he had
to say about his show
[Music]
the Osmond the ultimate showman Grace in
the stage since the age of five by seven
he was already a Vegas fixture I've
Waited All My Life Heather to do a show
like this because it's all inclusive
everything I've done and somehow we
squeeze it into a 90-minute show that's
six Decades of show business I mean I
keep pinching myself for the fact that
this is my show and I'm on the strip and
we've gotten awards for it and it's it's
just a it's a dream come true what you
can expect
performance to rival any headliner what
you might not expect
a wrap it All Began back in Utah I was
four years old started singing with my
brothers and the sound was like gold so
my folks took a leap and said what the
hey we got to get these monsters out to
California and it goes faster and faster
and faster 10 minutes long took me three
months to memorize this thing Donnie
says the show is an anthology of his
life so far including about 15 minutes
where the audience gets to request songs
how does that go I mean with 65 albums
how do you I can't remember what I ate
for breakfast it's a technical nightmare
it works 99 of the time it's all ages
and Donnie relishes the fact that he has
fans from every stage in his ever
evolving career a lot of youngsters come
here and they know me as Captain Shang
from the Disney movie Mulan it was like
this is a whole new generation of
followers
from Osmond Mania to Donnie and Marie to
this the longevity of his career
certainly not lost on him and he says
he's loving this time in his life I'm
very fortunate very lucky that I can
continue on it's such a fun show Heather
I enjoy getting on stage every night
[Music]
a great show it is stay tuned coming up
you're going to have a chance to win
four tickets and a VIP experience to see
Donny Osmond caller number eight will
win we're gonna put that number up very
soon stay tuned Sherry we can't win
though you and I
oh I won just for the chance of meeting
him once or twice that's true right
great guy I would never guess that
Donnie was a rapper though
that was a curveball he did it well that
was a surprise all right love him
beautiful Skies this morning could see
just a few clouds off in the distance
we've got some moisture that's still
circulating around the area and we'll
look at what it may bring us as we get
into our Monday and the rest of the week
lots of 70s just updating the valley
numbers Nellis is the only neighborhood
dropping down to the upper 60s a few
breezes out at Red Rock and up in the
spring mountains this morning outside
the valley Pahrump Indian Springs you're
in the 60s low 70's for Mesquite in
Boulder City still in the low 80s for
Laughlin some 60s around Kingman looking
for thunderstorms today thunderstorms
possible for Cedar City 54 in Caliente
51 in Tonopah and 52 in Reno look at
those chilly 30s up in Ely well
yesterday afternoon we did get some
thunderstorms right around Boulder City
late in the day right there lots of
lightning some heavy downpours nothing
for the valley but it looked so ominous
like a big mushroom cloud like an atomic
bomb was going off off to the southeast
this great photo from John saxo was sent
to him in the late day yesterday the
sunset light the golden light was cast
on the clouds off to the East and it
just gave it an eerie look but thank you
for sending in those pictures we've got
an explode we had an explosion of
thunderstorms all around the four
corners in the desert high pressure
around the Four Corners low pressure in
Utah in Colorado and that moisture is
lingering today so that's why we've got
the slight chance of thunderstorms in
the forecast hurricane Orlean is on the
coast of Mexico doesn't look like as it
makes its way Inland it will be a threat
to the desert Southwest but it certainly
will bring Heavy Rain to Coastal and
Inland Mexico as it becomes a tropical
and then post tropical becoming a low
pressure over the next couple of days
lots of flooding expected there in
mudslides 92 degrees for us with a very
slight chance of afternoon and evening
thunderstorms and then by tomorrow
really a drier northwesterly flow will
bring us nice sunny skies for the rest
of the the week temperatures don't budge
much in the extra warm low 90s we should
be in the upper 80s but by the weekend
we've got some 80's inside and that's by
Sunday into Monday with Mornings in the
cooler 60s 619 we got to check the drive
here's Nate a little bit of better news
but still one problem on the 15. so the
generally the freeway is in pretty good
shape as you're trying to get safely out
the door before 6 30. definitely getting
heavy on the south 15 out of the
spaghetti Bowl you're also tapping the
brakes on the 95 515 southbound after
Charleston down towards Boulder Highway
earlier crash has cleared it was
blocking Lanes of Eastbound Flamingo
right at the 15 our live picture showing
that has all cleared out so that is the
good news but we wanted to take you down
to the I-15 Northbound so coming from
Southern Highlands or St Rose Park when
you're going Northland on the 15. I
don't think you can make the exit at
Star Avenue you'd have to go up to
Cactus for that one and work your way
around here's a live picture showing you
what we're talking about not only is the
exit block but so is that far right lane
north on traffic having to get off to
the left hand side and there's more Good
Day Las Vegas right around
11 only on 8 News Now
[Music]
welcome back hey do you have a tough
time getting to sleep at night
you probably know this you're not alone
one in five Americans reports struggling
to fall asleep according to a new survey
from the Ohio State University Wexner
Medical Center Dr Anisa says from the
pandemic to politics people just have
more stress and worries these days and
stress can make it hard on your body to
completely relax so if you're struggling
to catch those Z's you might try
relaxation therapy
one form is progressive muscle
relaxation where you progressively grow
through your body to relax your muscles
another one is guided imagery where you
really focus on a story or a scene and
it helps you to focus on something other
than all the things that we're stressing
about
all right well of course you know this
bad habits can also impact sleep about
half of Americans well we're on our
phones before we go to bed and then
about a third apparently fall asleep put
the TV on all right Nate try to get some
sleep well hopefully you're awake in
front of the TV right now 6 25 on your
Monday morning what's driving you crazy
how about another round of closures Lane
restrictions Advantage Department of
transportations big project at
Charleston and the 95 515. so this is a
heads up for drivers who use Pecos under
the freeway starting tonight and running
every night until Friday morning at five
you're gonna have to find another way
now we're suggesting that you use Mojave
and even during the day when Pecos is
open under the 95 515 like it is right
now it will be closed tonight the
ongoing endot work is going to take
Lanes away in fact there's a ton of work
that's going to be going on all around
Charleston in the 95 515 until scheduled
completion in 2024. now all of this
information is at endos 515 Charleston
website we've got that link in the
online version of this story at
8newsnow.com when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving to Crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com Sherry 6 25 Nate if you
can't stick around for your full
forecast let's give you a look at your
accurate day planner for your Monday
we're starting out with clear skies
temperatures in the 70s this hour near
80 by mid morning and mid 80s by noon
see some clouds around and just very
slight chances of thunderstorms for our
Monday afternoon highs will again be
above normal in the low 90s a little
muggy with that extra moisture around
today and again slight chances of
thunderstorms even for the valley
through the early evening hours so watch
the skies if you're Outdoors Heather all
right Terry thank you gas prices
unfortunately On The Rise once again
after weeks of price declines we'll tell
you what's fueling the recent hike and
the big question is will it last you are
watching Good Day Las Vegas live local
now
[Music]
honor only three days a week in Fall
it's the law
now on good day a second LDS temple is
coming to Las Vegas a look at the Mormon
Church's growth here in our valley plus
five years after the one October
shooting the Vegas strong 5K the Las
Vegas Community continuing the healing
process and promoting police Community
Partnerships free events Metro Police
will be putting on tomorrow you and the
whole family can enjoy Good Day Las
Vegas starts right now
now this is good day Las Vegas live
local now welcome in here at 6 30 Monday
morning and I saw my neighbors had the
pumpkins out already and I keep thinking
I don't know
if they're the fake ones they're fine
yeah these ones might melt yeah yeah
we've had a real one sitting kind of in
the driveway between the garage doors
and I keep checking its pulse every day
just to see how it's doing and
we've got some warm days ahead of us and
it was a really warm weekend so much
going on this weekend and we'll start
off our Monday with clear skies as you
can see out there sun is just a few
minutes away from rising and we still
have just a few clouds off in Arizona
where it was pretty active over the
weekend and we saw some thunderstorms
off in Boulder City yesterday afternoon
lots of 70s out there this morning
Nellis just about the only spot in the
valley with 60s 35 percent humidity and
dew points are in the 40s this morning
so we start out kiddos with clear skies
good Sunshine but by the afternoon a
very slight chance of thunderstorms and
temperatures again will be above normal
in those low 90s you got to watch the
skies on the walk home just in case we
have some of those thunderstorms around
and getting started lightning Gusty
winds and maybe some brief heavy
downpours so be very safe out there
let's get to the roads and the drive
here's Nate all right Sherry thank you
so much so generally the freeway is in
pretty good shape you're for sure
slowing down on the 15 South out of the
spaghetti Bowl but the lanes are open we
do have one crash working this is on the
far south side and this is for the north
Hunters on the 15th so we're talking
about Southern Highlands or inspirada
whatever as you get on the north on 15.
it is a parking lot and you cannot make
the exit at Star Avenue let me show you
what we're talking about here Nevada
State Police Highway Patrol there's
somebody actually going ahead and making
that exit so even though it appears to
be closed I don't know if that's the
best idea but a lot of Emergency
Equipment Northland on the 15 after St
Rose Parkway squeeze over to the center
or the left and maybe make the exit at
Cactus Heather all right Nate thank you
6 32. a new LDS temple is coming to the
west side of the Valley Church of Jesus
Christ of Latter-day Saints announced
the new location will sit on a 17-acre
plot of land around on Lone Mountain
it'll be the lds's second temple in Las
Vegas according to the church nearly six
percent of Nevada's population are
active members the Lone Mountain Nevada
Temple will be the state's fourth temple
all right take a look at your screen
here Metro Police need your help finding
this missing 16 year old girl Vanya
Garcia she was last seen Saturday she
was in a black zip up Hoodie blue shorts
and pink shoes at the time if you have
any information on where she might be
call Metro Police that number is on your
screen it is 702-828-3111
looking ahead a former president Donald
Trump will be holding a rally in
Northern Nevada on Saturday campaigning
for GOP Senate hopeful Adam laxalt and
gubernatorial nominee Joe Lombardo
Republican Lombardo and Democratic
governor Steve sisalak debated during a
town hall last night this is footage
from a q a session held between the two
a few weeks ago Hot Topic last night
voting the two disagreed about how to
conduct elections in the future sisalak
arguing voters should continue to
receive ballots by mail Lombardo saying
ballad should only be sent to voters by
mail by request midterm elections are
November 8th and to get you ready here
at 8 news now we want to make sure
you're prepared so starting today we're
gonna have a special 30-minute program
giving you all the information that you
need to know ahead of election day on
November 8th Brian Loftus will be
hosting that show we'll have interviews
on all different topics large and small
again that's this afternoon at 3 30.
[Music]
our city coming together over the
weekend to remember one October five
years later
this was the scene Saturday night as
people gathered at the healing Garden to
honor the victims and survivors of that
tragic day we spoke with minda Smith her
sister Naysha Tonks was one of 58 names
read aloud honoring those that we lost
five years ago she spoke a little bit
about her sister and the memory she
wants to keep alive
he was a mom she was a daughter and
sister and loved friends and loved life
no child should ever lose a parent no
parent should ever lose a child
and you know it's hard it's a void that
we can't fill and the boys don't want
filled but you know you just wrap your
arms around them as much as you can and
just continue to move forward with love
800 people were injured that night five
years ago 58 were killed
two later died from injuries they
suffered bringing the death toll
officially to 60 making it the deadliest
mass shooting in modern U.S history
Sherry
well along with remembering comes
healing and that takes one step at a
time the Vegas strong 5K hit the streets
of downtown Las Vegas Sunday morning and
reminding everyone that it can be a long
road but a healing Road nade and Heather
J.C Fernandez and I we covered the race
it was fun we brought you live coverage
at 8 A.M maybe you saw us we got to talk
to some wonderful people really enjoyed
that the race has raised over a quarter
of a million dollars each penny going to
scholarships and victims funds since
2017. our eight news now team spoke with
one Runner who lost her cousin that
night on one October five years ago she
traveled from California to participate
in this year's run
my cousin was amazing she was 22 years
old and full of life laughter she loved
country music she loved to sing dance
and and she was just an amazing person
her smile was contagious
so wonderful to remember those lost more
than 2 000 people registered to run this
year and a big congratulations to that
gentleman right there he finished first
over all 16 minutes and 45 seconds I do
want to say give a big shout out this
was the 8 news now team right there on
the race course and just some of the
team we had a lot of folks registered
who were also working the race so it was
fun to see all the teams that came out
in support of the Vegas strong 5K
Heather yeah I saw him too incredible
groups of people a lot of smiles as as
we move forward and heal a bit and
perhaps maybe you saw this woman here
take a look it's our City's newest
residency performer country music star
Miranda Lambert she was out at the race
her husband there former NYPD running in
the race she posted these photos to
social media of course you can catch
Lambert's velvet Rodeo Vegas residency
inside Zappos theater right now but she
she was there there and she did also
honor the victims at her concert on
Saturday night
still to come here on good day A
desperate search right now for survivors
authorities continue to assess damage
that was left behind by Hurricane Ian
we're going to bring you the very latest
Straight Ahead Sherry beautiful skies on
this Monday morning we've got a few
clouds off in the distance but clear
skies right here in the valley
temperatures in the 70s now on our way
to near 80 by 9 A.M mid 80's by noon and
more clouds around this afternoon with a
very slight chance of maybe some
afternoon thunderstorms little humidity
little moisture lingering those slight
chances could last through the evening
hours and don't go away because we are
giving away a chance to win four Donny
Osmond tickets and a VIP experience to
his show at Harrah's it's all coming up
after the break on Good Day Las Vegas
live
Raiders games
you're watching Good Day Las Vegas with
John langler Heather Mills Sherry swinsk
and Nate Tenenbaum Good Day Las Vegas
live local now hurricane Ian's
destruction in Florida is Indescribable
at least 82 people are confirmed dead
there and four more in North Carolina
President Biden plans to visit Florida
Wednesday after visiting Puerto Rico
today as CBS correspondent Christian
Benavides reports from Fort Myers Beach
Florida's road to recovery will be long
and uncertain for many
hurricane Ian carved a deadly path of
Destruction across Florida in only a few
hours but the ongoing rescue and
Recovery will take time and resources We
are continuing the first priority which
is saving as many lives as possible such
a big storm brought so much water that
you're having basically what's been a
500 year flood event in some parts of
Florida flooding is getting worse the St
John's river in Seminole County keeps
Rising those nearby need boats to get to
their home we're at the deep end so I
think these first three houses or four
houses are all flooded and the rest are
just getting flooded on Sanibel these
volunteers brought residents of the hard
hit West Coast Barrier Island to save it
came up about four feet in the house
so I've been living upstairs here in the
Fort Myers area the damage is so bad
local elected leaders have used words
like catastrophic and life-changing to
describe the devastation this street
just one example of that it's lined with
boats wash the Shore by storm surge Lee
County officials meantime continue to
defend the timing of their evacuation
orders less than 24 hours before Ian
made landfall warnings for hurricane
season start in June and so there's a
degree of personal responsibility here I
I think the county acted appropriately
the thing is that a certain percentage
people will not heed the warnings
regardless as a new week begins more
than half a million Floridians remain
without power
CBS News Fort Myers Beach Florida
the 6 44 tomorrow night Metro is hoping
to nurture its Community Partnership
with National Night Out the annual and
National event bringing communities and
local police departments all together
for an evening of fun our Candace
Charles joining us live from downtown
Summerlin where that event will be held
Candace that is a pretty cool ride you
got behind you
yeah you checking this out Heather I
know it is pretty cool and I've already
been in it guys so I'm going to give you
a little sneak peek of course because I
always got you covered good morning
folks now National Night Out will be
happening tomorrow here in downtown
Summerlin this is an event that really
happens really throughout the nation has
been happening since 1984. as a chance
for you to come on down and get to know
your local police officers and I'm
joined by Captain Sims he of course is a
really nice dude and you can come and
get to meet him for National Night Out
tell us a little bit about National
Night Out what people can experience and
really creating those bonds with the
community well this truly is community
oriented policing it's a chance for you
to come out bring your kids it's a free
event and you get to know the police
officers that work in your community and
unfortunately it's usually on your worst
day when you get to meet a cop but this
is not this time not this time no so you
get to see some of our great resources
K-9 is going to be out here our
motorcycle cops are going to be out here
so it's a it's a fabulous event well you
got me at canine Captain says thank you
but besides that you guys get to check
out this YouTube TV that was offered up
by the Howard Hughes Corporation I'm
joined by Matt Walker from Howard Hughes
talks about this partnership and why you
guys decided to do this it's a pretty
nice new vehicle here sure well the
Howard Hughes Corporation is really
excited to partner with Captain Sims and
his team at some early command our
partnership with the Metro Foundation is
foundational to what we do in building
Community we think that this is about
the cleanest it's going to be so we do
hope that folks come out and get a good
look at it before uh before it gets all
dirtied up but it's critical uh when our
neighbors are in need that we get there
as quick as we can and this is going to
help reach some of the harder to reach
areas of Summerlin and we're thrilled to
be a part of it awesome thank you Matt
thank you again Captain Sims now I'm
gonna hop inside so I can show you a
little bit of what it looks like on the
inside but you can come on down here
tomorrow from five to seven and check it
out yourselves the seats are nice it
smells good in here come on down and
check it out of course I got you covered
with the details on haydenhithal.com as
well hi there I'll see you later I'm
going off in my new ride oh look at her
she's going and maybe they've got one of
those little air freshener things in
there for now it's clean for now as
Candice says man that goes fast alright
sure I'm gonna send it over to you
outside it's an out of sight literally
all right Donnie fans it's your chance
to call and win caller number eight